ti piacciono i computer è una domanda
innocua penserete voi anche io pensavo
fosse così
peccato che dieci anni fa il mio capo mi
ha fatto questa domanda è la mia vita è
cambiata lavoro infatti da quella famosa
risposta per questo istituto delle
nazioni unite che si occupa di ricerca
sulla criminalità della giustizia unicri
e da lì mi si è aperto un mondo
perché io mi occupo di ricerca su vari
aspetti di della criminalità nello
specifico di criminalità informatica
quindi quello che vi vorrei un pochino
raccontare oggi è proprio cercare di
capire quali sono i rischi che troviamo
sul web quali sono i rischi delle nuove
tecnologie e quello che è interessante
del mio lavoro che io ritengo essere un
lavoro bellissimo e che collaboro con
privati con istituzioni con ricercatori
con accademia con con la società civile
per scoprire quali sono i rischi ma
dall'altro lato anche per capire un
pochino
noi come facciamo essere un po più
sicuri online e come riusciamo a rendere
spesso si è detto prima un mondo
migliore ecco come riusciamo a rendere
anche internet che una parte
fondamentale della nostra esistenza un
mondo migliore
lavoro con interpol con europol con la
nato per cercare di formare personale
militare poliziotti per capire questi
rischi e la cosa interessante che tutti
insieme si mettono insieme le forze
appunto per raggiungere un risultato che
sia uno sforzo collettivo da dove sono
partiti sono partita con un progetto che
mi ha aperto anche qui un mondo
totalmente nuovo
un progetto sulla profilazione degli
hacker ovvero capire quali sono le
diverse caratteristiche se così vogliamo
utilizzando la tecnologia del profiling
quella che viene utilizzata non so per i
serial killer ad esempio applicando nel
mondo dell'hacker
vi racconto solo un aneddoto era una
sera a cena e ragazzi di fianco mahon
cominciato a chiacchierare gli ho
chiesto ma tu cosa fai
e lui mi dice a quero satelliti io ho
detto sì vabbè a quero satelliti vado in
hotel
google ea caravà satellite e ho detto ok
c'è qualcosa che non va e quindi abbiamo
iniziato a parlare
e quella è l'essenza un pochino
dell'hacker nel senso una persona
curiosa che ha voglia di comprendere
io ho detto sai che c'è voglia di
comprendere anch'io comprendere come al
giorno d'oggi il termine anche è
diventato un pò sinonimo di criminale i
criminali sono tutt'altra cosa ovvero
sono interessati tendenzialmente al
profitto a che tipo di profitto tutti i
tipi
soprattutto si dice oggi che ogni nuova
tecnologia apra le porte a nuove forme
di criminalità è un pochino vero cioè
tutti i servizi che noi utilizziamo
quindi da internet ai social network
piuttosto che viviamo nel mondo
dell'internet delle cose le smart cities
eccetera
possono anche essere un veicolo per i
criminali per vari forme di criminalità
c'è chi è stato truffato
chi ha affittato una casa che poi non
esisteva ci hanno provato la carta di
credito furto d'identità
purtroppo vittime di stalking di
bullismo e oggi quello di cui vorrei
parlare e diciamo un aspetto forse un
pochino più scuro ancora e partendo da
un paio di concetti importanti uno è non
pensiamo più alla ker
il ragazzino che vedete nei film che fa
codice entra nel pentagono
adesso abbiamo criminali sempre più
organizzati che hanno creato un vero e
proprio mercato parallelo è che cosa
sono interessati
prima vi ho detto il profitto sì ma il
denaro se ci pensate una volta che lo
spendete non ce l'avete più chiacchiere
interessa una cosa un po diversa una
cosa che molto più legata alla nostra
vita ovvero i nostri dati perché perché
se ci pensate i dati si possono vendere
ad altri hacker ad altri criminali si
possono riutilizzare si possono creare
profili falsi
sapete quanto costa il vostro profilo
facebook con i vostri follower con i
vostri amici sul mercato nero due
dollari e 50
siamo chip e la cosa pazzesca che adesso
si vedono sempre di più comparire sul
mercato nero anche profili come ad
esempio i nuovi servizi quindi huber
spotify itunes
e qui scatta sempre la domanda ma si può
essere sicuri al cento per cento come
facciamo essere più sicuri vi porto
brevemente a fare questo giochino non so
quale passò riutilizzate ma dovete
sapere che le password più utilizzate
fino a inizio di quest'anno sono 1 2 3 4
5 6 e password e quindi ho provato a
fare questo giochino utilizzando
password su questo tool che potete
tranquillamente utilizzare in cui
mettete la vostra passato e vedete
quanto ci impiega un più possibile
criminale a fare un attacco che viene
chiamato brut forcing ovvero cercare di
indovinare velocemente quale può essere
la vostra password ci impiega
esattamente zero secondi
proviamo come ad esempio non so ogni
volta che provate a digitare una
password vi dicono metti una maiuscola
metti un carattere speciale proviamoci
un secondo forse se ci mettiamo un po
più di creatività utilizzando ad esempio
questa probabilmente riusciranno ad
azzerarla ma forse abbiamo un po di
tempo per fare qualcosa nel frattempo
non soltanto troviamo i nostri profili
online ci sono anche altri aspetti
ovvero che non occorre più estre
criminali esperti per diventare dei
cybercriminali si possono comprare
determinati tool come virus
oppure si possono assumere gli hacker
questa è una foto del porto di anversa è
un gruppo di trafficanti di droga ha
pensato ma invece che fare tanta fatica
perché non attiriamo il sistema di
monitoraggio dei container del porto di
anversa e facciamo passare i container
prendi droga e ci sono riusciti ma dove
si trovano gli atroci dove andiamo ad
assumerli
andiamo di assumerli come vi ho detto
prima nel mercato nero dove sta il
mercato nero dovete immaginarvi che in
internet ci sono 550 miliardi di
documenti google indicizza 2 miliardi
quindi meno dell'un per cento ed è
quello che chiamiamo surface web
subito sotto c'è quella parte che viene
definita deep web di cui si sente tanto
parlare
pensate non so al database della società
per cui lavorate non è indicizzato su
google e poi esiste una parte ancora più
profonda che la parte del barco web cosa
succede lì è calata in una retta che è
caratterizzata da forte
perché vi si entra attraverso torre che
questo di onion router è un software
interessante sviluppato all'interno di
un progetto militare americano per avere
una comunicazione anonima quindi quando
voi utilizzate questo software siete
irrintracciabile in rete cosa succede
che questo è un ottimo tool un ottimo
strumento per ad esempio la libertà di
espressione per i dissidenti politici
chiaramente immaginate bene il terminale
ha detto è il perfetto
chi è il criminale tipico il vicino di
casa che tutti vorremmo avere questo vi
presentano sul brit nato nel 1984
come vedete direi abbastanza un bel
ragazzo lui fa ha una laurea in fisica
master ingegneria la university e decide
invece che farmi assumere questo suo
profilo linkedin dice sapete che c'è
faccio una start up e crea silk road
filtro de il mercato della droga online
più grosso che voi possiate immaginare
13.000 tipologia di sostanze
stupefacenti indicizzate e adesso è
stato arrestato
gli è stato dato l'ergastolo e deve
risarcire il governo americano per 180
milioni di di dollari ma esiste anche un
aspetto forse più vicino a noi che
stiamo fronteggiando in questo momento e
quindi ci spostiamo da questa parte che
il dark web alla parte in cui tutti
siamo ovvero il surface web
quello di cui vi vorrei parlare in
questo momento è un aspetto molto più
delicato che sicuramente non si può
esaurire in pochi minuti e soprattutto
non saltano dal punto di vista tecnico
ma a partire dal qaida in poi quello che
stiamo vedendo un utilizzo massiccio da
parte dei gruppi terroristici di
internet perché così attraente così a 30
perché in un secondo poi raggiungere
moltissime persone e quindi utilizzarlo
come strumento propagandistico questa è
il tweet aggio live quindi esattamente
come sta accadendo per te vicenza c'è
stato qualcuno che nel 2014 ha twittato
live la presa di mosul che una città in
iraq è stata conquistata dall isis
quindi abbiamo questo e poi hanno capito
anche un grandissimo vantaggio il potere
di raggiungere persone che prima
dovevano magari sarà incontrate
fisicamente e adesso invece appunto
pensate al fenomeno dei foreign fighters
si possono contattare persone molto
distanti e avvicinarli alla propria
ideologia queste aic boucheron siriano
canadese che ha creato dei diciamo così
dei gruppi su skype quindi uno strumento
che utilizziamo tutti per
l'indottrinamento nello specifico
spiegava al corano in italiano
alle ragazze circa 300 ragazze iscritte
e della persona che si pensa abbia avuto
un ruolo fondamentale nel reclutare
l'altra ragazza che vedete nella foto
maria giulia sergio che è stata la prima
ragazza italiana a raggiungere
a seguire la lotta dell'isis in siria e
qui c'è sempre la parte pugno nello
stomaco in cui ti chiedi qual è la
soluzione e disconnettersi totalmente e
spegnere il computer spegnere il
telefono e la domanda è sempre ma
effettivamente dobbiamo avere paura e io
mi sentirei di dire forse una paura sana
un pochino sì recentemente qualcuno ha
detto che internet è la più grande
invenzione dell'umanità dopo il fuoco
io trovo siano analogia perfetta perché
internet proprio come il fuoco
all'inizio l'uomo si scottava col fuoco
ma poi ho imparato col tempo utilizzarlo
internet è un giovincello appena
compiuto trent'anni in italia e quindi
dobbiamo ancora imparare a capire un
pochino come interrelazione arci con lui
esiste una formula magica di sicurezza
informatica no come avrete capito
esiste una cosa molto più importante che
è avere degli utenti consapevoli perché
internet fa un po meno paura quando
abbiamo degli internauti più consapevoli
grazie